how do you judge a movie
this is a great question because
i think everyone judges a movie
differently
a lot of people will judge a movie based
on
its visual style
its score its production value for me
its kinda has to be the complete package
and i think it starts
with characters
characters and story are key you can
have the most beautiful looking film in
the world
but if i watch a movie and the story
doesn't connect with me
and i don't care about any of the
characters it doesn't matter how good
the score is doesn't matter how good the
costumes are
doesn't matter how great the
cinematography is
the story sucks
the movie sucks
and i think
that's something
that i struggle with a lot
nowadays
when it comes to films because if you've
noticed
there's become this very
bad pattern
in the industry
where everyone has said visually
stunning everything's visually stunning
cinematic
no matter what it is
and you're like you watch these movies
and it's like what's with these
characters like why are they
underdeveloped why are they like
doing these like what's what's the
reasoning behind their actions
and that's what i focus on so like for
me
characters and story are key to any
movie
and it doesn't matter to me
it doesn't matter
if a movie
doesn't have like the most
i don't know
spectacle of direction
but if you have a story that connects
with viewers
that will elevate the movie almost in
every way sure you can say like oh if
someone so directed this movie don't you
think it would have been a little bit
better sure
but
i still think it comes down to
those two key elements of
you have to have characters that are
going to resonate with an audience and
you have to have a story
that's going to connect with an audience
and that's all it is to it because
nowadays visual movies are a dime a
dozen every marvel movie is a visually
stunning movie every dc movie is a
visually stunning movie every star wars
movie every animation all of that stuff
visually stunning it's what goes into
the meat and potatoes of like those
characters and the story that's being
told that makes it worthy of your time
or not
okay elvis
visually stunning but
excellent characters yes would you agree
yes okay yes yes
and i i have to say with elvis
it's a balancing of tone in a weird way
too because
i know a lot of people are criticizing
tom hanks's character in that movie oh i
didn't know that yes a lot of people are
criticizing it because it's kind of very
over the top it's almost like almost
like a dr evil type villain like i'm so
menacing and the way that baslerman
shoots certain scenes with him it's kind
of almost like he's going like oh yes oh
yes
oh this is mine
right so i
i watch some of this and i'm kind of
like okay like this is a little over the
top here
but when you go into like a
rock star life
they hit upon so much in this two and a
half hour run time of you know his
stuff down in in memphis and his impact
and his drug addiction his women abuse
his his claim to fame of like being
inspired by the music in the black
community there's so much that they're
trying to cram in here that in a weird
way
i almost found it refreshing that tom
hanks was in this movie being like this
character that was like over the top
because it took away from how serious
the rest of the movie was
and i think
you have austin butler literally putting
in a performance of a lifetime in this
movie like i just
it's been such a long time i was
thinking about this i think it was like
ray charles with rey was the last time
that i seen an actor
totally like just become
another person
and and this is not like prosthetics
like you know gary oldman and darkest
hour like his great performance don't
get me wrong but it's the prosthetics
right you you forget it's him because of
all this this makeup and hair with this
it's just like
the voice it's it's the commitment just
like it was with jamie foxx
and you watch this movie
and you just again you fall in love with
the characters right it's austin butler
becomes elvis and the movie's about
elvis and you fall in love with that
character and you like the journey and
it's like
critics are like ah
it's overlooking certain things in his
life like these biopics
that we all know nowadays
you have to have rights to tell this
story and there's going to be very few
people
who are going to let you [ __ ] on their
[ __ ] on that person they're not going to
say oh yeah you know what
show how terrible he was when like
family members are still alive they're
not going to do that just like we saw
with bohemian rhapsody the band didn't
want to go through all the dark stuff in
there they they touched upon it just
like they do in elvis
but it does glance over things but the
bottom line is you still have a
character and you're telling a story
about fame and fortune
and like this love of of of music right
and love of like performing and what it
is to
feel the crowd and wanting to travel
around the world and you know sadly
elvis never got to do that he only got
to do it within the states and because
of stories that we got to hear in this
movie
but
it was great because you connected with
the character and you understood it's
it's a dreamer movie right elvis was a
dreamer
and those are the movies that
i think for me are the ones that i
resonate with the most
because those are the ones that are kind
of universal in their messaging which is
why when you see a movie like elvis
people will clap at the end of it when
you go see it with a regular audience
because it gives them this this level of
hope but at the same time elf is not a
happy movie like at the end of it it's
kind of sad
but it gives you that that full meal you
get that's that like the climb effect to
fame
the the life of fame the bad side of
fame and then like trying to find your
voice within there
and then the tragedy of what it is and
so i think it's a really
well-structured movie as a whole again
not perfect
but very few movies are
right and in going into the movie it was
moving very fast i thought oh no this is
going to be one of these rushed biopics
yeah visually stunning as it was but but
it something about it hooked me in and i
didn't feel like it was rushed but in
the beginning i wasn't sure if that's
where we were going i think that's
because it's bazlerman right i mean
bazlerman as a filmmaker
very hit or miss and as much as again
you can have visual style and you could
never take that away from basilarman baz
lerman has a very specific look and feel
to all his movies the way he
incorporates modern music with old
school music he does it's his signature
style
and what i was worried about with elvis
was
i thought like great gatsby
where it overtook the movie right like
it was so much of like modern music in
there and it was so over stylized
that you just you kind of forgot like
this is a great piece of literature with
great gatsby and that's all like lost in
the spectacle
but with elvis i think
it's weird because i think i saw an
interview with him that he wasn't like
the biggest elvis fan in the world right
like he wasn't like you would think when
you're doing a biopic you would pick
someone who's like obsessed
and i think he he admitted that he
really wasn't obsessed he knew of him
and he was kind of fascinated with him
but he wasn't like oh my god i have to
do this like this is not like his dream
project
but like he somehow made it into his his
dream project
and i think
that's kind of capturing austin butler
right it's like
i love movies where they find an actor
who has really not been taken seriously
before
and you put him in this world and you
create this story around him
and everyone just like people who hate
elvis
can say at the very least that austin
butler didn't give at least a good
performance some people might be like me
where they're extreme and go like this
is one of the best performances that
i've seen in like 10 years
but
most people would say that a lease is a
good performance
people are mixed on the movie but the
performance so i think baslerman really
does
with this one i think he understood
that it was more about the story
and more about the character
than it was about the visual he wanted
to create his sense of style he had to
put it in there which is why if you
watch the first half of that movie it's
much more of a traditional baslerman
movie with everything he does thrown at
you but the second half of it is way
more of just kind of like okay this is a
story this is where like things where
the [ __ ] hits the fan things are going
to get real here and we're going to
focus on that
and it really is
kind of uneven to be truthful but i
think that second half is so strong that
it actually makes up for the first half
right and i was worried about that would
that would the payoff in the end
wane because everything was up front and
would you say that's almost a smart
thing for a filmmaker not to be too
obsessed with someone's life story
because it's going to be biased if they
go in sort of neutral
yeah i mean i mean this ties into so
many different things
i think
being a fan of someone
is very difficult now
because again going back to the internet
it's almost like oh you're the go-to so
this is no surprise to anyone who knows
me i'm a big kristen stewart fan and i'm
a big kristen stewart supporter and i
have been since speak when it premiered
at sundance
but
i can admit that not every movie she
does
or has been a part of is good
sometimes she's not good in the movie
sometimes the movie's not good sometimes
she's the best part of the movie
sometimes the movie's great and
everything's great
as a filmmaker i agree i think it's it's
really hard because if you really
idolize someone
it can go either one or two ways
it can go so extreme
where you're just like the ultimate
fanboy fan girl
and you're just like making this love
letter
that is just like
oh my god i idolize this person i love
them so much
and then if you don't you have on the
other end of that if you have someone
who doesn't know anything about the
person you run the risk of kind of not
being
accurate and not feeling the heart
because biopics in a weird way
need that middle ground
you have to love someone
in into on a certain
extent but you also
have to realize that they're flawed and
that they're not perfect and that they
have
dark sides
and that's i think what really stood out
to me about this and it even
rocket man right rocket man
elton john was so
involved with it right but ellen john's
the type of
celebrity who's not afraid
of what people think because
he hosts oscar park
he's like the one of the most beloved
people in the industry you know like
so he's not really afraid to show his
dark side of things
but
is queen
afraid of showing their dark side
probably because they're still touring
and they're still making money freddie's
not here anymore but they're still part
of it so they don't want anyone to kind
of see something and kind of view it and
go like
i don't know about those guys anymore
right and that's where i think you
you have this really fine line of
everything right you have
how much do family members have this
involvement in this movie are they are
they controlling it too much that it's
not accurate enough
and then do you have a filmmaker who's
capable of telling the story
that it doesn't feel like a documentary
you know like where it's actually going
to be to me documentaries
are so one-sided majority of them right
you're watching a documentary and you're
kind of like
okay this is like set out to be like
tell me like michael moore
he hates trump i know you hate trump you
know like no no so like you're not a
surprise you're watching this movie
you're watching this documentary you're
not surprised no one
who likes trump's going to watch this
movie
so like who are you making this movie
for but when you go to biopics too i
think that it has that problem too
because you want to learn something
when you watch a biopic
that you don't
that you don't always need the the clean
and shiny version of it you want some
darkness but there's a there's a balance
and i i don't know
i feel like biopics are always getting
such like mixed reactions from critics
and rightfully so because they either go
too heavy
or not
heavy enough
and there's like there's there's no in
between with all of them
and
one of my favorite movies of recent
years and i and i enjoyed the fact that
it was more of the spectacle
is the greatest showman
because the greatest showman
is not trying to be this biopic right
they literally made up characters in the
movie
it was just supposed to be a musical
that's fun and entertaining and then
when i'm reading critics i was like
they didn't show the dark side of his
life i'm like
at no point did this movie say that it
was going to be this hard hitting tale
about this it was supposed to be a
light-hearted thing
so i understand why some people watch
elvis and they criticize of how they
grow you know glossed over things and
how they watch bohemian rhapsody
but at the end of the day these movies
are appealing to the masses the
what
what we as film critics sometimes want
is not what the studio wants nor what
audiences want
that's a good point because in the
theater was a couple that could not stay
off their phone they were online
shopping but they eventually put it away
so obviously it got their attention
enough from close to the beginning and
then there was another family that was
at one point standing up just talking
but but we were able to finish the movie
as a group so very diverse
group that was in there but somehow
their attention
as much as they kind of wanted to squirm
and do things was kept
and and and i agree on on showing the
different sides is difficult in the film
one film that i'm kind of a broken
record on is this john delorean movie
which was a movie within a movie so it
was several independent filmmakers who
were hoping to make a documentary on him
and it was a narrative it was his family
members and they all came together to
kind of give different sides of the
story of how it transpired and i thought
that was fascinating i hadn't seen too
many like that yeah so and alec baldwin
plays uh john delorean and he's as
himself contemplating what what would
john have done in this scene and things
so that would seem like it was more of
an all-around representation but i get
it we only want to see sort of one
version of the person yeah i mean
and it's all based on who you talk to
right
so the biggest issue with biopics now
right
is that you have the movie that the
studio wants
you have the movie that the director
wants
you have the movie that the audience
wants you have the movie that the
critics want
and it's very very rare that all four of
those people are going to agree
and i think that's a huge problem which
is why i think
biopics always gets such a mixed
reaction it's because
it leans in one like right like rocket
man was leaning into the dark side and
because it's ellen john it did really
well
but it didn't do as well as a bohemian
rhapsody
because that
leaned into more of the spectacle
and more of the music you have 30
minutes at the end where you have that
um what is that aid
i forgot the name of it but they have
the the aidc live aid scene at the end
and they're just performing i mean that
is still probably one of the best scenes
in a movie in the last decade because
it's just it's just it's it's musical
spectacle it's queen
why we love queen
and
rocket man even though they kind of had
like almost like a broadway
approach to it of like here's a musical
number we're going to bust into a
musical song here and then look then
we'll go through a set and blah blah
blah it's great
but people really love those moments
where it's just like 30 minutes of like
this is what i want this is what i want
and again critics not so much audiences
yes same with musicals people want
they want to feel like they're watching
a stage musical
on the big screen and sometimes those
numbers are not big enough they feel
very small
so yeah it's it's really trying i don't
i don't envy people who are doing these
these jobs anymore because you're
appealing to so many different people
and it's really difficult now because of
what we talked about earlier social
media
everyone has a voice
and everyone has something to say so
what one person might love another
person hates and it depends on who picks
that up and who runs it as a headline as
to whether or not that movie will will
sink or float